this week on brian ross investigates
a day of reckoning for the man whose
millions of followers call him the
apostle jesus on earth
nasan garcia admitted in court he
sexually abused young girls at his
church
do you remember
when you wanted me
to bring my little sister to you
so that you can violate do
they saved countless young girls in this
church from being
abused by this man
and sentenced to prison and as to the
defendant i say
you are a sexual predator
ben has lived a term state prison of 16
years and eight months
dozens outside the los angeles
courthouse protesting
some of his victims say the apostle got
off easy it's a slap in the face
they slapped us in the face
plus this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of media
height
from the studios of the law and crime
trial network in new york city's herald
square
this is brian ross investigators
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to everyone watching us
on facebook live i'm brian ross joined
as always by my colleague ronda schwartz
and ronda we begin tonight with the day
of reckoning for a man who calls himself
the apostle the leader of a church that
claims five million members in the
united states and around the world they
saw joaquin garcia has now pleaded
guilty to sexually abusing young girls
in his church under a plea deal that
some of his victims felt let him off too
easily rhonda
that's right brian at the sentencing
hearing in a los angeles courtroom
prosecutor patricia fusco said no man of
god would ever do what he did to these
victims the so-called jane does who in
emotional testimony told the judge of
the impact of his crimes on them all as
garcia stared straight ahead stone-faced
never looking once at his victims
i am chained to four
i am overwhelmed with emotion
as i stand here today
i want to start by clearly stating that
nassau
and this church
have ruined my life
every aspect of it
i have suffered
more trauma and pain than i can ever
begin to describe
all i have ever wanted was to see my son
go to trial for what he did to me
us
to speak the truth in this courtroom
my truth
and to tell the world who this man
really is
i had no way out
you didn't just read me over and over
again
you were evil and merciless
i went from being an innocent virgin
to experiencing
the most violent revolting treatment
ever
do you remember
when you wanted me
to bring my little sister to you
so that you can finally do
i told you
she's only 14.
do you remember what you said to me
do you remember saying that i should
have brought her to you sooner
do you remember
when you commanded me
to have sex with one of your dogs as
your 50th birthday present
do you remember telling me how much you
wanted your husky to defile me
was you raping me not enough
i'm done
i'm tired of being blamed by everyone
not with people telling me this is so
to the world i'm trash into church of
failure
and i'm not ready to tell anybody
but i had to
but soon i will
mason
the time has come
today is the day
the time for people to know what you put
me through
i'm raising my voice here in this court
in front of the evil monster who if you
used to be here
and raped me and broke me
for so long i didn't have a voice
and i didn't think that anyone would
care enough to hear me
and the prosecutor told the judge that
the five young women who had come
forward to testify had paid a price for
their bravery being threatened by
members of the church
i'm imploring every member of this
church today to stop harassing these
women
they are not enemies of the church
they are brave enough to stand up to
this man
they should be heroes in all of their
minds
they say countless young girls in this
church from being
abused by this man by being brave enough
to come forward and now he'd go into
prison
under the terms of his deal garcia
pleaded to only three of the 36 counts
he was originally charged with some
three years ago
judge ronald cohen was unsparing in his
sentencing of the church leader and i'm
never ceased to amaze
be amazed that but some people do
in the name of religion
and how lives are ruined in the guise
of serving a supreme being
as of the jane does
at this point
i apologize my hands are tied
lawyers
do what lawyers do at this point my
hands are tied but i further want to
tell all the jane does
that the world
has heard you
i promise you that
as to those family members
that have abandoned the jane does
shame
shame on you
and as to the defendant i say
you are a sexual predator
fenn has lived a tournament state prison
of 16 years and eight months
it's fair to say that no one has worked
harder to bring the apostle to justice
than social market
social now that he has pleaded guilty
and been sentenced to prison what is
your reaction
well brian my reaction and that of the
the reaction of
the victims of nathan joaquin not only
sexually
were we
violated by him but we were also
extorted we were trafficked and these
young women
and i'm talking about the miners in in
this particular situation
we're talking about children here
they were trafficked they were sexually
assaulted by mr garcia
and they were violated by the entire
organization and still still they made a
deal with a sexual terrorist
prosecutors say that may have been the
best deal they could have made what do
you say to that
i say that they
it's a slap in the face
they slapped us in the face and they put
us in a hole
that's what i think and i think it's all
bs
that that's the best deal they could
have made that's bs
there's something very eerie and very
wrong
going on in this case
the church now says we will wait for you
apostle what does that mean in terms of
any change inside this church
there's not an internal investigation
going on in the light of the world
that's never existed they've always
always supported this pedophile this
rapist this criminal and who he himself
just confessed that he was and still the
bishops and the hierarchy are still
lying to the members
social you put your life on the line and
others did to come forward to testify
and provide evidence to prosecutors uh
do you now fear there'll be some sort of
retaliation against you and the others
who came forward
oh absolutely
absolutely
this will
absolutely happen
um
they don't understand that this is not
an
organized religion
this is an organized
institution of criminal activities this
has been running for 96 years and these
are people that run like come they they
they act like common thugs like common
thieves and they are they will do
anything in order to make sure that this
enterprise maintains itself sturdy and
strong
what do you intend to do now well
there's a
there's a ricoh civil suit this is a
racketeering case and so this is a
federal racketeering case and we expect
the the federal authorities to come in
and finish what the department of
california the department of justice of
the state of california couldn't do
so what do you say to the california
attorney general
how dare you
so outrage doesn't seem to describe the
depth of your feelings here social
no i i just i
i'm leaving
all of my my pain and i'm leaving all of
my sadness aside because i need to be
strong
i need to be strong because there are so
many survivors out there that can't
speak for things for themselves i will
not sit down and cry
i will not sit down and give up and
cross my hands and and wait and see what
happens
i can't
so for you the fight for justice is
still far from
over oh it's just beginning this is the
beginning of their end
social martin thank you so much for
being with us here tonight
thank you brian for having me
when we come back the apostles church is
standing by him saying its millions of
members still don't believe the charges
against him despite his plea of guilty
to being a predator pedophile you're
watching brian ross investigates on the
law and crime trial network
one of the women who was set to testify
against the apostle was one of his
so-called handmaidens alondra ocampo she
had already pleaded guilty and agreed to
turn against him her husband christopher
kellermeyer talks about what happens
next
is her reaction to his guilty plea and
the deal he cut with the california
attorney general when she heard that she
started crying and
she uh got nauseous really um
you know she told me on the phone that
she became nauseous because
she's thinking about you know all the
people who are going to continue to be
victimized once he's back in front of
the church especially her people in
mexico
the long arm of
the united states
law won't be able to get to them
so the church says they're going to wait
for him what do you think that means
it literally means that that they'll be
praying uh
for him they'll be receiving his
instructions from jlb letters and
correspondence so you think in other
words it means nothing really is going
to change in that church
exactly so what does this mean for your
wife then
well it's devastating for her because
well what it means for her with the with
the uh
with the pleading guilty is that nothing
changes she was prepared to testify
hoping she could put him behind bars
correct
yes
and you know not er for what he did to
her for what he did to other girls for
how he's manipulated people and just
treated people are basically just cash
cows
it's a business you know and it's also
you know
a generation so it's a system that
creates generations of abusers and
victims
so what is her message what is your
message to members of the church tonight
she's saying this is all true and it all
happened and
this is very sad that it
that he'll be
probably alive and
in 10 years and be able to be back in
front of the church
and able to harm people again how do you
feel about that
i i think
i think it's horrible but you know
alandra is also very sad too because her
parents still don't believe her and
uh
that's very sad for her
uh because you know the people that
brought her in this world brought her to
this church
uh
they are are
basically calling her a liar still and
so
yeah it's not a good time right now for
anyone in terms of happiness
because
a lot of family members are still you
know adhering to that faith
and
sticking strong to it you know just
it's unfortunate
christopher calamari thank you so much
for being with us here tonight
no problem
the lawyer for miss ocampo has been on
both sides of the legal battle over the
apostle working first for the defense
until his client cut her own deal he
says the deal now cut by the prosecutors
with the apostle makes sense to him
you've been involved in this case now
for several years what do you think led
the attorney general's office to accept
this plea deal
well at the end of the day they want uh
the surety that
you know the apostle is going to be held
accountable for his actions although
there was a slew of evidence against him
you just never know how a jury is going
to react you never know how a trial is
going to
unfold
and the apostles defense team
is amongst the best in the nation led by
allen jackson so there was always the
chance
that something might go awry furthermore
um
by accepting a plea they don't have to
put the victims through the trauma of
testimony and cross-examination and i'm
sure that was
uh one of the considerations that they
took into account
when reaching this plea bargain with
nasa
some of the women some of the survivors
feel that he's getting off easy
what do you think
i think 16 years
is
um
i think some people might view that as a
light sentence in comparison to the
to the gravity of what he has done and
the charges that he is facing
uh however you know there's a old saying
a bird in the hand is with two in the
bush
and um you know at the end of the day
he is pleading guilty to sex crimes he
is being sentenced to double digits
so
you know could the attorney general's
office have pressed for a few more years
possibly
um but i think this is still a
considerable sentence
you know uh for
for a man who just you know a few years
ago was
was was the head of a church and beloved
by all
and now the church says we will wait for
you suggesting they'll wait for him to
come out of prison that perhaps he can
run the church from behind bars what's
that message he's already making excuses
for what he's done but you know i mean
is this a surprise this is a man who has
committed atrocities you know in the
name of the in the name of god in the
name of his church and everything is an
excuse you know this is oh this is it's
not me that's doing this this is what
god wants you to do how do you think
he'll do in prison for the next decade
or so
not too well um you know but i
you know
sex offenders and people accused of
muslim children
uh always have a difficult time in
prison but you know i'm sure he'll
survive i doubt it'll be happy
uh and it shouldn't be
all right fred
thank you so much for being with us here
tonight
thank you brian
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media you're watching brian ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media group an aiden
who's chosen as you're a winner this
week the actor matthew mcconaughey a
hometown boy from ovalty texas who took
to the white house press room to talk
about the need for gun legislation
maite wore
green high top converse
with a heart she had hand drawn on the
right toe because they represented her
love
of nature camilla's got these shoes can
you show these shoes please
wear these every day
green converse with a heart on the right
toe
this is the same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
how about that
a powerful presentation by a skilled
actor aidan that's right uh so matthew
connery delivered this incredibly
emotional speech from the white house a
press briefing room
two reporters there and it lasted
roughly 20 minutes
and he recounted the stories of the
children that were murdered at robb
elementary school in uvalde texas where
he is from
it was an incredible ode to those
children it was so powerful that uh you
could see there uh karine john pierre
the press secretary even shed tears um
he also made a call for gun reform um he
outlined that uh this is not a partisan
issue or that it should not be and he
laid out a few responsible gun reform
measures that he thinks
should be passed which include expanding
background checks red flag laws
waiting periods for rifles that are very
popular like the ar15 and raising the
age to buy those weapons from 18 to 21
years old now matthew kane is an
incredible messenger i think on this
issue
because he is from texas
he speaks a lot about his family values
he also said in the speech that he was
raised revering guns and had a lot of
guns growing up
and he also said that you know in uvalde
he spoke to a lot of these parents who
themselves said that they support the
second amendment but they still think
that there should be limitations on it
so that massacres like this do not
happen at elementary school specifically
i think a testament to how good that
speech was from the white house podium
uh in the press briefing room was the
fact that fox news anchors actually
praised matthew mcconaughey in the
aftermath and even fox news news's
partisan primetime opinion hosts refrain
from attacking him which is not
something that they usually do when it
comes to hollywood actors that disagree
with them on politics and for this
week's losers fox news first decision
how to handle the january 6 committee
hearings that's right so we have the
january 6 committee hearings that are
starting this week
fox news is not airing them in prime
time which all other news networks are
doing now this is not surprising at all
the hearings start at 8 pm which is
right when tucker carlson's show airs um
tucker carlson's show is the most
popular one on fox news and he has spent
the last couple of months railing
against these hearings um so the idea
that he would air them in full like the
other networks are doing um it strange
credulity but it's still deeply
embarrassing for fox news these are
eminently newsworthy hearings and now
fox news is taking their two best
anchors bret baer and martha mccallum
and making them host uh the hearing
special over on fox business which is
viewed by far fewer people than fox news
so it does a disservice to their readers
and it's a little bit of a stab
journalistic responsibility here and yet
they're sticking with that decision
yeah they are despite the immense
backlash and you know fox news says that
they're airing it on their streaming
platform fox nation in full they're also
airing it on fox business um but it's
suffice to say that fox news is what's
viewed by most people and they will not
be airing these hearings so much of the
country will see them but not the
regular viewers of fox news that's right
aidan mclaughlin thank you so much for
being with us here tonight and thanks to
all of you for joining us here i'm brian
ross investigates we'll see you again
here next week
[Applause]
you